à quelques centaines de mètres à vol
d'oiseau de l'usine à sucre des bassins
au creux de la ravine saint-gill au lieu
dit bassin la pompe se trouve une roue
hydraulique enserrée dans un mur de
soutainement mise en place vers 1825 au
moment de la construction de la sucrerie
de saint-gill Léo elle est aujourd'hui
encore présente en dépit du démontage de
certaines pièces en fonte de son
mécanisme abandonné sur le sol d'un
diamètre dépassant 6 m cette roue
métallique était mise en mouvement par
le remplissage en eau de ses godets
depuis une canalisation située dans sa
partie
supérieure un système d'engrenage
constitué de roues denté actionnait une
pompe qui aspirait puis refoulait l'eau
de la ravine en direction de
l'établissement
sucrié les chaudières à vapeur pouvent
alors alimenté après la fermeture des
portes de l'usine en 1920 la roue est la
seule source d'approvisionnement en eau
potable de la propriété jusqu'en 1968
elle alimentait le grand bassin de
l'usine ainsi qu'une citerne bâtie dans
le village attenant situé à
l'emplacement de l'ancien camp
d'esclave